and applebaum is here with me she writes
for the atlantic she's a historian and
political analyst and what do you take
away from this munich security
conference
i take away that there is real unity in
the west that
americans germans the british
the french the european union are all on
the same page they've agreed that there
will be very harsh sanctions on russia
if there's an invasion of ukraine
um there's a tacit agreement that some
nato countries some western countries
will be supplying weapons to ukraine
i also take away the fact that the
ukrainians
feel this isn't enough
president zielinski made a speech that
was in which he made clear that he's
grateful for what's been done
but at the end of the day ukraine is
alone
and it will really be up to the
ukrainian army
and the ukrainian
public
to repel
what could be a very large invasion and
so the the disconnect between those two
views
um gave a little bit of dissonance i
think to this event it was a very
passionate speech by vladimir zelensky
quite clearly a man who's very much
under pressure we took also a great risk
coming here because he was advised by
joe biden he really shouldn't come he
shouldn't leave the house unguarded
he did take that risk and he called out
the west really to give him a timeline
ideally for security he wants security
he doesn't simply want aid is he going
to get that anytime soon he will not get
a western military invention
intervention
there is no consensus in favor of
american or european
boots on the ground as we say in english
soldiers in ukraine you know fighting
with the ukrainians that's not going to
happen
he may get military he's had quite a lot
of it already in the last few weeks
and he will get on his behalf
these very harsh sanctions of russia
um but at the end of the day the the the
this war will be decided if there's a
war
will be decided based on
what the ukrainians themselves do
and it may well be actually that putin
has
really underestimated ukraine um
he doesn't know ukraine well he has many
you know kind of
misapprehensions about it um in this
famous essay that he wrote last summer
putin wrote a long essay describing
russia's relationship with ukraine
he he was he proved himself rather
ignorant actually of ukrainian history
as the ukrainians understand it um and i
do think there's a there's a willingness
to fight and
even if the um you know the initial
battle is lost it will not be at all
easy
for russia to stage some kind of
occupation of ukraine if if that's still
what's in his head
you've written extensively also on the
whole cold war you've mentioned this
kind of view of vladimir putin that that
past the post-soviet past was a
historical mistake that he wants to fix
at what kind of historical moment are we
right now
so putin is someone who was deeply
affected by the collapse of the soviet
union and the collapse of the soviet
empire in 1989 and 1991 he's himself
said this and written about it he
considers it a great mistake and a
disaster
he's also someone who is very
anxious about even obsessed with
democracy rhetoric democracy activism
the kinds of moods and emotion that
brought people under the street in
leipzig
and berlin in 1989 and led to the fall
of the berlin wall
the kinds of demonstrations that led to
the collapse of the
pro-russian dictatorial president of
ukraine in 2014
he's afraid of those kinds of movements
coming to russia he sees himself at war
with democracy and with the democracies
he perceive we don't perceive him as an
ideological enemy but he perceives us
that way and for him ukraine is really
the symbol of this you know ukraine is a
country that he thinks should be russian
or absorbed into russia or close to
russia he sees that ukrainians want
something different
they want to be a sovereign democracy
they want to trade with the west they
want to be integrated into western
institutions and for him this is a line
too far
this is really not about nato that nato
is a distraction
this is about putin wanting to protect
his own power and his own political
system you know he he is a one-man
autocrat you know he runs a kleptocracy
the system is set up so that he and his
close contacts
not only rule russia they own most of
the larger russian companies they profit
from them they want to keep that system
in place and they perceive
democratic activists anti-corruption
activists
um you know
any any any
any any street movements any public
movements any public sentiment as a
threat to them and so the attack on
ukraine and the
decision to destabilize ukraine which
has already begun it's already underway
um is really part of that it's about
protecting his own position and his own
power can you make any kind of
prediction of what playbooks are on the
table right now how this could turn out
well there we know the russian playbooks
because they're the soviet playbooks and
we've seen them before i mean invade a
country put in a puppet government you
know they did that in 1945 you know
we've seen that in in east germany in
poland and in in hungary in those years
um more recently we've we've seen him
you know go into he went into georgia in
georgia he didn't um
he didn't capture the capital but he
went in he destroyed all the military
installations he took some land and left
that's by the way another scenario
that he might be considering um so we
know what he does we you know we've seen
this many times and he hasn't been all
that subtle in denying that he would do
it again so so one of the reason that
particularly american leaders are
are worried is because they they know
what he does they have intelligence that
says he's at least considering trying it
again
um and
you know in the past those kinds of
uh those kinds of invasions have left
many people dead and created a lot of
destruction vladimir zelensky the
ukrainian president basically accused
the west of appeasement in the past in
relation to russia from the
conversations you've had also talking to
hearing european leaders here what kind
of
state is europe in and what kind of
state are transatlantic relations europe
feels very unified
people are saying the same thing
there were a couple of very good very
powerful speeches here the american vice
president was very good
um the german chancellor was very good
the german foreign minister was very
good um but but it amounts to the west
saying we are unified in support of you
um we are going to put the harshest
sanctions on russia there have ever been
um but we will not fight for you
um and so at the end of the day it's
going to be up to
the ukrainians to fight for themselves
and they will fight
and the question is whether
their kind of warfare which will look
much more like asymmetric
guerrilla warfare
will be enough to stop a very
sophisticated russian army
so what kind of phase are we entering
into now in this conflict
is this going to be with us
months years decades what's your
expectation so i think the russian
assumption is that it would be very fast
you know the war would be over very
quickly
and
for all i know that that could be true
the main part of the fighting but the
ukrainian resistance that will be real
and will last indefinitely
will make any kind of occupation of
ukraine or any kind of russian
domination of ukraine extremely
difficult and so we could be in for a
very long term
you know kind of guerilla war that lasts
for a long time and of course by
definition that would affect nato states
like poland and also probably germany um
there would be
you know there would be weapons that you
know that would go into ukraine there
would be you know a lot of traffic back
and forth between ukraine and countries
on the border
um and that would have a
kind of both i think both destabilizing
and galvanizing effect
on the rest of europe
okay well and applebaum writer for the
atlantic and historian thank you very
much for analyzing that for us thanks so
much thank you
you